O
THIS SPECIAL EDITION OF FOX
NATION I'M GREGG JARRETT MY
GUEST TODAY SEAN HANNITY YOU OF
COURSE USE HOST OF HANNITY ON
THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL AND THE
SEAN HANNITY SHOW ON RADIO
ACROSS THE NATION AND HE'S JUST
COME OUT WITH A NEW BOOK YOU
CAN PICK IT UP IN BOOK STORES
OR ONLINE. IT'S CALLED LIVE
FREE OR DIE AMERICA AND THE
WORLD ON THE BRINK SEAN GRADY
WITH YOU FIRST- WE'RE GREAT
FRIENDS I'VE INTERVIEWED YORK
THE NUMBER ONE BEST SELLERS-
AND I COULDN'T EVER DUPLICATED
BUT- IT'S GREAT TO DO THIS
THANK YOU FOR COMING IT'S A HOT
DAY SO WE START SWEATING SO
PEOPLE KNOW WHY- BUT ANYWAY
THANK YOU THANKS FOR TAKING THE
TIME THERE THERE'S A LATIN
PHRASE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
BOOK EXPLAINING. LIVE FREE OR
AMERICA DIES. IT WE WERE
TALKING AHEAD OF TIME. AND WE
KNOW THE FAMOUS PATRICK HENRY'S
GIVE ME LIBERTY OR GIVE ME
DEATH WE KNOW THIS THE MODELS
SLOGAN OF- NEW HAMPSHIRE'S LIVE
FREE OR DIE. AND I'LL BE HONEST
I WATCHED YOU POUND OUT EVERY
SINGLE WORD TO YOUR BOOK EVERY
NIGHT YOU'RE TWO BOOKS BECAUSE
YOUR OFFICE IS NEXT TO MINE.
AND I HAVE ANOTHER BOOK IN TEN
YEARS. THE MOMENT. IS CRITICAL
THIS IS A TURNING POINT TIPPING
POINT ALL THOSE THINGS WE
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT CHOICE
SELECTION. IT'S THE BIGGEST IN
OUR LIFETIME AND THE STAKES
COULDN'T BE HIGHER. AND I
WANTED TO GET IT LAID OUT THE
CASE SO ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY
COULD KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IS AT
STAKE HERE. AND I'VE NEVER EVER
BEEN AS WORRIED FOR THIS
COUNTRY THAT IS SO GREAT AS I
AM FOR THIS COUNTRY NOW RIGHT
AND IT I MEAN IT IS EVERY ISSUE
IT'S NOT JUST SOME ISSUES IT'S
EVERYTHING. I THINK THE RACES
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS AND I THINK THAT
NOW IT'S IT IS VERY CLEAR CUT I
GO THROUGH VERY QUICKLY WE GET
INTO MORE DETAIL IF YOU LIKE.
BUT YOU KNOW IF YOU ARE HAPPY
WITH THE ANARCHY. THE
LAWLESSNESS THE LACK OF LAW NO
ANARCHISTIC OVER CITY BLOCKS
CHOP CHAS TO GET A POT LUCK
DINNER AUTONOMISTS SUMMER OF
LOVE IS ALL WE'RE INNOCENT
AMERICANS DIE. IF YOU'RE HAPPY
WITH THE ALL ON AVERAGE SIXTY
OR SEVENTY PEOPLE IN CHICAGO
THAT- SHOT EVERY WEEK AND THEY
DON'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
BIDEN AND BARACK DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT THEY EIGHT
YEARS THEY WERE IN OFFICE. IF
YOU'RE HAPPY WITH THE BILE TO
NEW YORK CITY OR IF YOU AGREE
WITH JOE ON. YOU KNOW YEAH WE
APPS THE POLICE HAVE NOW BECOME
THE ENEMY. OKAY THERE ARE SOME
BAD COPS I WAS TALK DURING THE
WHOLE RUSSIA COLLUSION ISSUE
AND THE DEEP STATE ABOUT. THE
1% BUT I ALWAYS MADE A
DISTINCTION ABOUT THE 99% THE
SAME SAME FOR POLICE OFFICERS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
EVERY SINGLE DAY TO PROTECT AND
SERVE THEIR CITIES OR TOWNS OR
COMMUNITIES. THEY DESERVE
BETTER JOE BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE
ONE GOOD WORD TO SAY ABOUT HIM.
THE POLICE HAVE NOW BECOME THE
ENEMY WHAT AND YES I SUPPORT RE
ALLOCATING FUNDS THEY DON'T
LIKE THE WORD TO FUND ANYMORE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE THE WAY
IT SOUNDS SO THEY'VE- FOCUS
GROUPS A NEW TERM. BUT IT'S THE
FUND THAT'S WHAT THAT WORD
MEANS. IT'S LAW AND ORDER.
HIGHER TO. I MEAN JOE BIDEN IS
RUNNING ON DRAMATICALLY RAISING
TAXES ON EVERY AMERICAN. DONALD
TRUMP'S TAX CUTS HAVE CREATED
THE MOST MASSIVE. YOU KNOW
EMPLOYMENT RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS WE'VE EVER
SEEN AND IT BENEFITED. ALL
AMERICANS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN LEFT BEHIND
EVEN IN SPITE OF LIBERAL
DEMOCRATIC POLICIES THAT IS AT
STAKE IN THIS ELECTION NATIONAL
SECURITY ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
WHAT KIND OF PEOPLE WE WANT ON
THE BENCH I JUDICIARY
ORIGINALIST- SAY VERSES DOES IT
WOULD LEGISLATE FROM THE BENCH.
THESE ARE PROFOUND DEEP ISSUES
HERE'S ANOTHER ONE BORDER
SECURITY OR THE UNITED
SANCTUARIES US STATES OF
AMERICA AND AMNESTY AND THEN
FREE HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS FOREIGN POLICY YOU
ONE OF SOMEBODY'S FIGHTING FOR
BETTER TRADE DEALS SUCCESSFULLY
ALL THE PREDICTIONS THAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS A PROTECTIONIST NEVER
CAME TRUE. NONE OF IT CAME TRUE
BUT HE DID GET BETTER TRADE
DEALS WITH CANADA MEXICO JAPAN
OR WESTERN EUROPEAN ALLIES
CHINA. AND ELSEWHERE AROUND THE
WORLD AND WE'RE BETTER OFF
BECAUSE OF IN A MANNER AMERICAN
MANUFACTURERS SAW TREMENDOUS
JOB CREATION JOBS JEHLUM BROCK
SAID WOULD NEVER COME BACK.
THIS IS JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG IS THE OVERVIEW. AND AS
I GOT INTO THE SPECIFICITY IN
THE BOOK WE GO THROUGH ALL OF
THAT YOU DO IN FACT I WANT TO
QUOTE FROM THE BOOK SEVERAL
PARTS OF IT PAGE SIXTY. IF
EMPOWERED DEMOCRATS PROMISED TO
TAKE OR CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING
ACTIONS AND YOU LIST THIRTY-
THEM I'M JUST GONNA READ A FEW.
AND ACT THE NEW GREEN DEAL
BANNED FRACKING PACKED THAT
SUPREME COURT DOT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT A POLISHER NULLIFY
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE DOWNSIZE
THE MILITARY. ABOLISH PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE IMPOSE A
WEALTH TAX DEATH TAX INCREASE
THE TOP MARGINAL RATE 270% THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON. HE IS JOE
BIDEN ON BOARD WITH THIS. ON
BOARD HE'S TRIPLE DOWN ON IT.
THINK ABOUT THAT HE JOINED THIS
INSANITY POLICE OF THE ENEMY
REALLOCATE FUNDS FROM THE PLACE
NOW LOOK AT. WHAT HE'S NOW
EMBRACE JUST IN RECENT WEEKS.
AND THIS IS THIS IS A
PHENOMENON I THINK IT'S A SIGN
OF WEAKNESS I'M HOPING THAT I'M
RIGHT. YOU KNOW WE'RE LESS THAN
A HUNDRED DAYS AWAY FROM OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ELECTION OUR
LIFETIMES. OKAY WHO HE
LITERALLY THE PLAGIARIST THAT
HE IS HE'S PLAGIARIZE LET'S SEE
ROBERT KENNEDY NEIL KANIK-
OTHER PEOPLE AS WELL.
PLAGIARIZED A LOSS LAW SCHOOL
MAJOR IS RIGHT EXACTLY. THEN HE
LIFTED IN PLAGIARIZED.
BOLSHEVIK BERNIE SANDERS
SOCIALIST AGENDA. NOW WHAT
MAKES THIS UNIQUE IS. IS
WHETHER YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT USUALLY IN PRIMARIES
YOU'LL GO TO YOUR BASE YOU'LL
TRY TO SHORE UP YOUR BASE
BECAUSE THE BASES MORE
MOTIVATED USUALLY DEVOTE. BUT
IN A GENERAL ELECTION YOU MOVE
TO THE CENTER. JOE BIDEN DIDN'T
HAVE BERNICE BASS HE'S ADOPTED
AND LIFTED WORD FOR WORD HIS
ECONOMIC POLICIES OKAY THAT IS
PURE UNADULTERATED SOCIALISM HE
LOOKS TO AOC ALEXANDER ACOSTA
CORTEZ THE CONGRESSWOMAN. HE'S
ADOPTED HER NEW GREEN DEAL
AGENDA AND IS PLEDGING TO SPEND
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS. ON THE
NEW GREEN DEAL THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE OIL GAS COAL THE LIFE
BLOOD OF THE WORLD'S ECONOMY
AND ALSO OFFERS EVERYTHING TO
BE FREE. IT IS MATHEMATICALLY
UNSUSTAINABLE IMPOSSIBLE THESE
ARE DREAMS IT COULD NEVER BE
FULFILLED IN ANY UNDER ANY
SCENARIO. THEN HE'S GOT YOU
MENTION GUNS THAT HE'S HE'S
WORKING WITH- BETO I CALLED
BOZO OVERWORK. THE SAID YEAH
WE'RE GONNA COME KNOCKING ON
YOUR DOOR AND TAKE YOUR GUNS TO
PARTNER WITH HIM. THEN YOU GOT
BIDEN PELO SEE INSURE THEIR
ELECTED YOU GOT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE YEARS A SWAMP
EXPERIENCE. WE GOT A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF BROKEN
PROMISES YOU OUT OF HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WHAT THE HELL
OF THE DONE. TO MAKE THIS
COUNTRY MORE SAFE MORE SECURE
MORE PROSPEROUS. AND THEIR
TRACK RECORD IS ABYSMAL JOE'S
RECORD AS VICE PRESIDENT IS
EVEN MORE ABYSMAL HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET INTO THAT. AND SO
YOU'RE ASKING ME IF THEY JOE
BIDEN WILL DO THAT. HE'S
ALREADY HE'S EMBRACED IT HE'S
OWNING IT HE'S IT IS IT IS THE
ESSENCE OF HIS CAMPAIGN. BUT
WHAT'S STRANGE AND UNIQUE ABOUT
THIS GREAT. IS DEMOCRATS USED
TO TRY AND HIDE IT. MMHM THEY
USED TO BELIEVE IT BUT THEY
WOULD NEVER SAY IT. WHAT MAKES
THIS DIFFERENT IS. BECAUSE I
NEVER BELIEVED THAT THE COUNTRY
THIS COUNTRY. I ALWAYS BELIEVE
WILL RIGHT OF CENTER COUNTRY
MAYBE NOT AS CONSERVATIVE AS I
AM A MAYBE. IT'S YOUR
CONSERVATIVE I'M ASSUMING YOU
ARE KNOW FOR SURE I NEVER ASKED
YOU MORE IN THE JOURNALISTIC
SIDE THAN I AM OF THE WEEK.
VERY STRONG OPINIONS- I'VE
ALWAYS BELIEVED WAS SET RIGHT.
AT NOW. AT THE LEFT WAS SORT OF
MARGINALIZE THE BERNIE THE
BOLSHEVIK BIRDIES MARGINALIZE
THE- CONGRESSWOMAN. ALEXANDER
KASO CORTEZ WERE MARGINALIZED.
THEY'RE NOW EMBRACED BY THERE
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE. THIS IS THE NEW
EXTREME RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY WHAT DOES IT
MEAN FOR AMERICA. IF THOSE
POLICIES ARE ADOPTED ONE
EVERYBODY THAT'S WATCHING FOX
NATION UNDERSTAND THIS. IF
THESE POLICIES ARE ADOPTED. IT
WILL FUNDAMENTALLY ALTER AND
DESTROY IRREPARABLE HARM WILL
COME TO THE UNITED STATES.
THESE THIS IS A PIPE DREAM.
THIS IS A PRESCRIPTION FOR
UNMITIGATED DISASTER. AND THE
AMERICA THAT WAS BASED ON
CAPITALISM LIBERTY FREEDOM. A
DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC
CONSTITUTION. WILL EXIST NO
MORE. YOU WANNA KNOW WHY SAY
LIVE FREE IN A OR AMERICANIZED.
BECAUSE WHAT IS MADE THIS
COUNTRY SO SPECIAL AND SO
UNIQUE. IS THAT IT'S A COUNTRY
FOUNDED ON FREEDOM. FREEDOM
OKAY BARRY FARBER I ALWAYS CALL
CALLED HIM. IS ONE OF THE GREAT
PIONEERS OF TALK RADIO. AND
JUST RECENTLY PASSED AWAY. AND
HE ALWAYS WOULD SAY THERE'S
NEVER BEEN A COUNTRY HE SAYS
THERE'S NO PERFECT COUNTRY BUT
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A COUNTRY IN
THE HISTORY OF MANKIND. THAT IS
ACCUMULATED MORE POWER THAN THE
UNITED STATES. OF AMERICA AND
ABUSED IT LESS. I THIS NEVER
BEEN A COUNTRY IN THE HISTORY
OF MANKIND THAT HAS ACCUMULATED
MORE POWER ABUSED AT LAST AND
USE THAT POWER LIBERTY FREEDOM
CAPITALISM RISK REWARD. OUR
EXCEPTIONALISM CAN SAY THAT I
GUESS TODAY AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM TO ADVANCE THE
HUMAN CONDITION BECAUSE ALL OF
THE ADVANCEMENTS MADE BECAUSE
WE ARE FREE AND BRILLIANT
AMERICANS CREATE GOODS AND
SERVICES THAT PEOPLE WANT NEED
AND DESIRE- THAT MAKES THE
MONEY AND SOME OF THEM EVEN
GET. RICH IN THEIR HORRIBLE
PEOPLE BUT- YOU DON'T FORCE
PEOPLE TO BUY YOUR SERVICES OR
YOU DON'T FORCE PEOPLE TO BUY
YOUR PRODUCTS. THAT IS LED TO
SCIENTIFIC INNOVATION MEDICAL
BREAKTHROUGHS IT HAS LED TO
LET'S START WITH THE SIMPLE
STUFF IN LIFE IT USED TO NOT BE
THAT EVERY HOME HAD A WASHER
AND A DRYER AND A MICROWAVE AND
A BIG SCREEN TV AND A
REFRIGERATOR AND FREEZER. ALL
OF THESE ADVANCEMENTS THAT YOU
LOOKED AT OF NOW. I MEAN OUR
THROWAWAY CARS IN THE SOCIETY I
OWN THEM WHEN I WAS POOR WHEN I
WAS STARTING OUT MY ADULT LIFE
AND I USED TO FIX MYSELF I
PAINTED MYSELF I DID SHOOT TUNE
UPS BREAKS. ALTERS STARTERS YOU
KNOW ANY I CAN GET DONE I DO
MYSELF I OPEN THE HOOD OF A CAR
NOW AND I CAN'T DO A DARN THING
I HAVE TO TAKE IT THE REAL
MECHANIC AT THE DEALER. THAT'S
ALL BECAUSE OF FREEDOM FREEDOM
IS ON THE BALLOT THIS YEAR. ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT CHAPTERS
I THINK IS. SOCIALISM HISTORY
OF FAILURE- EM PEOPLE TODAY
SEEM TO THINK THAT SOCIALISM
YOU KNOW MEANS FREE STUFF. ARE
THEY HAD EVERYTHING'S FREE GRAY
HAVE NO IDEA THAT THE HISTORY
OF SOCIALISM YOU LAY THIS OUT.
METICULOUSLY IS A HISTORY OF
FAILED ECONOMIES DESTROYED
LIVES IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES
EVERY TIME YEAH IT EVERY TIME
IS THIS WHAT WE WOULD BE
LOOKING AT. YES DEMOCRATS WIN
THE SENATE IF DEMOCRATS WIN
BOTH THE HOUSE AND THE
PRESIDENCY. BIDEN BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE. AOC SURE PELOSI. THIS
IS THEIR AGENDA THIS THIS IS
RADICAL EXTREME SOCIAL EAT
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT ONE THING
IT'S FASCINATING WELL WE'RE
GOING TO GUARANTEE- YOUR YOUR
STUDENT LOANS FORGIVEN WE'RE
GOING TO GUARANTEE YOU AOB AT
THE RIGHT WAGE WOULDN'T
GUARANTEE WILL GOVERNMENT
VACATION GOVERNMENT HEALTHY
FOOD. GOVERNMENT INCOME
EVERYBODY LAWFARE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
GUARANTEE YOUR RETIREMENT AND
YOUR HEALTH CARE AND EVERY. TO
ME THERE'S A THERE'S A
PSYCHOLOGICAL PLAY IN THAT IN
THAT WOW OKAY I'LL NEVER HAVE
TO WORRY. THE STRESS OF LIFE
THOUGH THIS IS THIS IS THE
BEAUTY OF FREEDOM LIBERTY
CAPITALISM RISK FOR WARD IS
THAT THERE THAT STRESS IS NOT A
BAD THING. THE IDEA THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO FULFILL
THESE PROMISES SOCIAL SECURITY
HEADED FOR BANKRUPTCY MEDICARE
HEAD OF A BANKRUPTCY HOW DID
THAT OBAMACARE THING WORK OUT
GREAT KEEP THE DOCTOR KEEP YOUR
PLAN. SAVE ON AVERAGE AVERAGE
FAMILY TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. PER FAMILY PER YEAR NO
IT'S THE WORST. MILLIONS LOST A
DOCTOR'S MILLIONS LOST THEIR
PLANS ARE ON AVERAGE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AMERICANS ARE PAYING
2100% MORE AND IS ALMOST 40% OF
THE COUNTRY NOW THAT HAS ONLY
ONE. OBAMACARE EXCHANGE OPTION.
NOW THAT'S JUST THAT ONE
PROMISE THAT WAS WITH THE
BIGGEST LIE TOLD. BIDEN WANTS
TO DOUBLE DOWN ON IT AND EVEN
TRIPLE DOWN ON IT WHEN HE GETS
TO SOME DEAL WITH BERNIE AND
ELIZABETH WARREN. IF BIDEN EVEN
IS SIMPLE CONTROL DISEASE NOW
CAPITULATED TO THE MOST RADICAL
GROUP OF PEOPLE EVER. OF SAYING
EARLIER. YOU KNOW DEMOCRATS
USED TO TRY TO HIDE THIS
THEY'RE NOW OUT IN THE OPEN.
NOW THE QUESTION IS AMERICA
GOING TO BUY WHAT THEY'RE
SELLING. BACK TO THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL COMPONENT. OKAY
IT'S APPEALING THAT OKAY I'M
GOING TO BE SAFE. I'M GOING TO
BE SECURE I'M GONNA HAVE MY
STUDENT LOAN DEBT FORGIVEN I'M
GONNA HAVE GOVERNMENT HEALTHY
FOOD IN RETIREMENT AND HEALTH
CARE AND- OKAY SOUNDS GREAT.
WHEN YOU ADD IT ALL UP. IT'S
NINETY FOUR TRILLION DOLLARS IN
TEN YEARS WITH THE NEW GREEN
DEAL BECAUSE ROSSOLL
ELIMINATING OIL GAS COAL- ZERO
MISSIONS IN FIFTEEN YEARS
ACCORDING TO JOE PLANES CARS
TRAINS WELL OKAY SO THAT'S A
LIFE FOR THE WORLD ECONOMY
DONALD TRUMP FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN SEVENTY FIVE YEARS HAS MADE
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME AND EVEN A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME WE ARE THE
WORLD'S NUMBER ONE PRODUCER OF
ENERGY. ENERGY IS THE LIFEBLOOD
OF THE ENTIRE WORLD ECONOMY NOW
IF SOME GREAT ENVIRONMENTALIST
LIBERAL WANTS TO COME UP WITH
ALTERNATIVE ENERGIES THAT ARE
FREE LOWER PRICED THEY'RE GOING
TO BE MULTI TRILLIONAIRES.
GREAT GO FOR IT BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT TECHNOLOGY WE'RE
DEVELOPING SOME WE HAVE
PROMISED IN SOME AREAS AMONG
ALL OF THE ABOVE GUY WHATEVER
IS GOING TO WORK ON FOR. I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE GOOD
STEWARDS OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
THE PROBLEM IS AND I DON'T CARE
IF YOU TAKE THE FORMER SOVIET
UNION SCANDINAVIAN COUNTRIES-
EUROPEAN NATIONS EASTERN EUROPE
FOR OPENS AT EAST GERMANY FOR
EXAMPLE BEFORE THE WALL CAME
TUMBLING DOWN. AND EVERY TIME
YOU GIVE UP YOUR FREE EVERY
TIME YOU TAKE ON THE SECURITY
THAT THEY'RE OFFERING WHICH
ALWAYS PROVES TO BE FALSE
THERE'S NEVER BEEN THE
SOCIALIST PROMISE THAT'S EVER
FOR FILLED THAT IS THE FAILURE
OF SOCIALISM. YOU GIVE UP YOUR
LIBERTY AND YOU GIVE UP YOUR
FREEDOM AND WHAT USUALLY THAT
EMERGES IS SOME TYPE OF TYRANNY
ALRIGHT I MENTIONED IN THE BOOK
CUBA I TALK ABOUT VENEZUELA IF
SOCIALISM IS SO GREAT WITH ALL
THE ENERGY RESERVES. OF
VENEZUELA HAS THEY BE THE
RICHEST COUNTRY ON EARTH- JORGE
ROMMEL'S WENT THERE AND
ACTUALLY CHRONICLE PEOPLE
PICKING FOOD OUT OF OUT OF
GARBAGE TRUCKS. BECAUSE OF SUCH
POVERTY. THE WHEN YOU HAVE
STATE IS IN VIEW IT LENDS
ITSELF TO CORRUPT US IT ALSO
ELIMINATES FREEDOM. IT THEN
BECOMES TYRANNICAL IN MOST
INSTANCES. AND ALL OF THE
LIBERTIES AND FREEDOMS THAT DID
LEAD THIS COUNTRY TO THE
GREATEST STANDARD OF LIVING IN
THE INDUSTRIALIZED WORLD THEY
ALL GO AWAY. AND THAT IS THE
FAILURE OF SOCIALISM IT GETS
WORSE IN THE FORMER SO UNION.
YOU KNOW. LOOK AT THE WALL FOR
EAST GERMANY WEST GERMANY. ONE
OF THE LEAVE WHAT COUNTRY EAST
GERMANS WERE WILLING TO RISK
THEIR LIFE TO TRY TO GET INTO
WEST GERMANY RIGHT. UP WHY ARE
WE BUILDING WALLS IN AMERICA TO
KEEP PEOPLE OUT OUT IN. NO
BECAUSE EVERYONE WANTS TO
COMMENT. AND IT'S AMAZING TO
WATCH IMMIGRANTS TO THIS
COUNTRY AND I MET SO MANY
WONDERFUL PEOPLE IN MY LIFE
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD. THEY
GET THE FIRST SHOT OF FREEDOM
AND THE FIRST CHANCE TO BRING
THEIR GOD GIVEN TALENTS TO
FRUITION. AND YOU WATCH THEM
SOAR. I'LL NEVER FORGET.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN FINANCIALLY
INDEPENDENT SINCE I'M TEN YEARS
OLD BUT OF FIERCELY AND
INDEPENDENT KID- PEOPLE IS LIKE
THE FAMOUSLY RIGHT HANNITY'S A
COLLEGE DROP OUT. GUILTY AS
CHARGED. BECAUSE I WAS PAYING
MY OWN WAY. THROUGH COLLEGE I
NEVER TOOK A PENNY FROM MY
PARENTS FOR MONEY NEVER I GOT A
STUDENT LOAN THAT I PAID BACK
IN FULL. AND I WILL WORK FROM
THE TIME I WAS TWELVE WELL
EIGHT WITH A PAPER OUT. AND
THEN THE TIME I WAS TWELVE. I
WAS WASHING DISHES BY HAND IN A
BUSY RESTAURANT EVERY FRIDAY
SATURDAY SUNDAY- THEN I BECAME
A SHORT ORDER COOK THAT I
BECAME A BUSBOY THAT IT BECAME
A WAITER THEN I BECAME A
BARTENDER. AND I ALWAYS HAD A
LOT OF MY- POCKET STILL DO
ACTUALLY. THANKS TO THIS BY THE
WAY IT'S FOUR HUNDRED DEGREES
JUST SO YOU KNOW HE PICKED THE
HOTTEST DEGRADED TO BEER- I'LL
CHANGE CHURCH OCCASIONALLY WHEN
I NEED TO. THE BUT THOSE JOBS
MADE ME A BETTER PERSON THEN
ONE ELSE PAY MY WAY THROUGH
COLLEGE AND MAKE. I RAN OUT OF
MONEY AND I GO TO WORK THEN I
WENT INTO CONSTRUCTION. I
STARTED PAINTING HOUSES THAT IS
THAT LEARN HOW TO HANG
WALLPAPER. THEN I STARTED DOING
RECONSTRUCTION WORK THAT I DID
ROOFING FELL OFF THREE STORIES
OF ROOF. HIT THE GROUND BECAME
A CONSERVATIVE GOT A LITTLE
SITES NOT ATTEND. WELL THIS
PART OF MY OVER HERE THAT WAS
DANGLING SEPARATE- AND- AND I
BROKE THE RADIAL HEAD. MY
GRANDPARENTS CAME HERE ALL FOR
THEM FROM IRELAND THEY HAD
NOTHING. THEY HAD TEN DOLLARS
IN THEIR POCKET. MY FATHER GREW
UP POOR IN BED STUY. IN
BROOKLYN HIS MOTHER DIED ABOUT
FIVE WEEKS AFTER HIS BIRTH.
FROM COMPLICATIONS FROM
CHILDBIRTH- MY DAD WAS A BIG
DEAL WE FOUGHT FOR YEARS IN THE
PACIFIC OF MORE WAR TO. AND HE
WAS A BIG DEAL FOR HIM TO MOVE
FROM. BED STUY. TO LONG ISLAND
WAS A FAMILY COURT PROBATION
OFFICER AND OF WHAT AT A WAITER
ON THE WEEKENDS. AND MY MOM
GREW UP POOR IN THE SOUTH
BRONX. AND SHE BECAME A PRISON
GUARD WORK SIXTEEN HOUR SHIFTS
PRETTY MUCH MY WHOLE LIFE. SO
BUT FOR THEM. THEY STOOD ON THE
SHOULDERS OF. MY GRANDPARENTS
THEIR PARENTS. AND I STAND OUT
ALL THEIR SHOULDERS. AND THE
IDEA IS THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE.
CREATE IT- IN ENVIRONMENT AND
EVERY GENERATION YOU BUILD UPON
THE PREVIOUS ONE THAT'S THE
HOPE THE DREAM THAT IS AMERICA.
HOW DID WE INVENT ALL THESE
INCREDIBLE THINGS THAT WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW WE CAN GO BACK TO
HENRY FORD YOU COULD TALK ABOUT
CARS. YOU KNOW PLANES TRAINS
AND AUTOMOBILES- CONSTRUCTION
SKYSCRAPERS CITIES YOU NAME IT
THAT IS ALL AMERICAN GREATNESS
AND INGENUITY A LOT OF IT IS
BECAUSE OF. YOU KNOW THE
FREEDOM THE PEOPLE HAVE. TO
BRING OUT OF THEM WHAT TALENTS
GOD GAVE THEM THE LATIN
DERIVATIVE FOR EDUCATION IS. I
DO TODAY. TO BRING FORTH FROM
WITHIN. WELL THAT THAT'S
PREDICATED ON WHAT THAT GOD PUT
IT THERE WHAT IS OUR FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS SAY OUR DECLARATION
WE'RE ENDOWED BY OUR CREATOR.
THOUGH THERE WAS A NATURAL
RIGHTS GOD GIVEN RIGHTS. AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE DOWN BY A
CREATOR WITH CERTAIN
INALIENABLE RIGHTS LIFE LIBERTY
AND THE PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS BY
THE WAY YOU CAN'T PURSUE
HAPPINESS. IF YOU DON'T HAVE IN
SECURITY LAW AND ORDER LIKE IN
CHICAGO NEW YORK SEATTLE AND
PORTLAND. YOU YOU CAN'T PURSUE
HAPPY IF THE WRONGS OF THE
LATTER RIPPED OUT FROM UNDER
YOU. AND THE CASE SYSTEM IS
RIGHT. YOU WANNA TALK ABOUT THE
FAILURE SOCIALISM. HOUSE
AMERICA'S EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
THERE YOU GO YOU HAVE A GREAT
CITY OF BALTIMORE. YOU LOOK AT
NEW YORK CITY YOU LOOK AT
CHICAGO YOU LOOK AT BALTIMORE
YOU LOOK A PORTLAND YOU LOOK AT
SEATTLE YOU LOOK AT IT IN THE-
OF THE BIG CITIES IN LOS
ANGELES. WE AS A COUNTRY SPEND
MORE PER CAPITA ON EDUCATION
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN THE
INDUSTRIALIZED WORLD.
GOVERNMENT RUN EDUCATION. OKAY
BALTIMORE THIRD HIGHEST PER
CAPITA SPENDING IN EDUCATION IN
THE WORLD. THE CITY OF
BALTIMORE HAS THIRTEEN PUBLIC
HIGH SCHOOLS. GUESS HOW MANY.
KIDS OR WHAT PERCENTAGE OF KIDS
IN THE HIGH SCHOOL PROFICIENT
IN MATH. YEAH I WOULD IMAGINE A
VERY LOW PERCENTAGE ZERO ZERO
NOT ONE CHILD. REALLY HOUSE
THAT SOCIALISM WORKING OUR
GOVERNMENT RUN SCHOOLS WORKING.
I WANT TO BRING THIS TO A TO A
LEVEL WHERE PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE
BECAUSE- THE CITY IS THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING SO MUCH ABOUT AND
THAT THIS IS NOT IN THE BOOK
BUT IT FITS PERFECTLY WITH MY
ARGUMENT. THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
NEW YORK BALTIMORE CHICAGO WE
CAN PROJECT ON ANY GIVEN
WEEKEND BUT SIXTY SHOT SIXTY BE
SHOT THIS COMING WEEKEND
SEVENTY- TWELVE FOURTEEN DEAD-
HOW MANY CHILDREN WILL BE SHOT
WITHOUT A ONE YEAR OLD KILLED
IN BROOKLYN NEW YORK ON AN
EIGHT YEAR OLD KILLED IT'LL-
GEORGIA. A SEVEN YEAR OLD
KILLED IN CHICAGO- NINETEEN
YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN I
INTERVIEWED HIS FATHER HORACE
OF LORENZO ANDERSON SENIOR HIS
NAMESAKE JUNIOR KILLED IN THE
CHOP CHAS SUMMER OF LOVE ZONE.
THESE KIDS ARE NEVER COMING
BACK WE'RE LOSING THOUSANDS OF
THE OUR KIDS. SO HOW DID THESE
STATES THAT HAVE ADOPTED THEIR
MANY VERSIONS OR- YOU KNOW WE
SAY THE STATE'S R. OR FIFTY
EXPERIMENTS YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE ON
AUTONOMOUS IN THE SENSE THAT WE
BELIEVE. IN AND STATE'S RIGHTS
AND DURABILITY AND FREEDOM TO
DO WHAT'S BEST FOR THE CITIZENS
AND THEIR STATE. BUT ALL THE
CITIES OF ONE THING IN COMMON
THEY BEEN RUN BY LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES. THEY
HAVE FAILED SPECTACULARLY IN
THEIR NUMBER ONE DUTY WHICH IS
SECURITY AND SAFETY ALL OF
THEM. THEY'VE ALL FAILED. OUR
NATIONAL TREASURE. OUR CHILDREN
ARE DYING OUR MOMS AND DADS ARE
GETTING SHOT. OUR AMERICAN
FAMILY ARE GRANDMOTHERS AND
GRANDFATHERS THEY'RE GETTING
SHOT AND MANY OF THEM ARE
DYING. YOU KNOW THE PRESIDENT'S
RIGHT WHEN HE SAYS THESE ARE
WAR ZONES CORRECT. CPO AT YOU
ADD THE EDUCATIONAL FACTOR. IF
YOU CAN'T READ WRITE DO MATH
AND HISTORY AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS ARE
FAILING YOU ONE FORGET
AMERICA'S DREAM IT'S YOUR SHOT
OUT IT'S OVER WE HAVE FAILED IN
THEIR OWN THAT SPECTACULAR
LEVEL SO ADD THE SOCIALISM ALL
THE PROMISES THAT YOU POINT OUT
PAGE SIXTY IN MY BOOK. ALL OF
THEM AND YOU TELL ME WHAT IS
GOVERNMENT DONE SO WELL THAT
WOULD THEY WOULD WARRANT US
PUTTING MORE FAITH HOPE AND
TRUST IN THEM MANY OF THE
ARGUMENTS YOU'RE MAKING TODAY
ARE IN YOUR NEW BOOK LIVE FREE
OR DIE AVAILABLE ONLINE AT
AMAZON .COM PROBABLY BARNES
KNOW AND I DON'T I DON'T
HANNITY .COM THERE'S AN ERROR
IT IS. ONE OF THE CHAPTERS
CHAPTER FIVE TO NEWS IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT EXCLAIMED
KICK I CAN'T HOW DO YOU IN THIS
CHAPTER I BY THE WAY I THOUGHT
OF A LOT OF THAT IS I'M DOING
THE CHAPTER IT'S CALLED THE
HOAX THE CENTURY ARE IN WE
EXPLAIN IN EXCRUCIATING DETAIL
BUT APPROPRIATELY BETTER ALL
HOW. AND THE FBI KNEW IT WAS A
HOAX MILLIE DISCOVERED
DOCUMENTS NOW SHOW THAT YET
THEY LIED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IS THIS IN YOUR JUDGMENT
WHAT. OF GOD TO BE CORRUPT ON.
FIRST BIGGEST IS A CORRUPTION.
IN AMERICAN HISTORY. YOU HAD TO
NUMBER ONE BY. BOOK ON THIS
VERY TOPIC BOTH OF IT DON'T
HOPE YOU DON'T MIND I STOLE YOU
KNOW WE COULD CALLED AS A BLACK
I WATCH. YOU GO THROUGH THE
DETAILS THAT THERE WAS A ON
SITE CALLED THE ENSEMBLE CAST
OF US. YOU WERE A BIG PART OF
IT JOHN SOLOMON WAS A BIG PART
OF IT JOE WOODIN VICTORIA WERE
A BIG PART OF IT- I'M GONNA
MISS PEOPLE- THAT SARAH DID YOU
PUT. THIS IS A THREE AND A HALF
YOUR- YOU KNOW OR- THAT THIS
COUNTRY WAS PUT THROUGH. WE
WERE RIGHT AND THE MOB IN THE
MEDIA WAS WRONG THEY LIED NOW
THE PROBLEM IS THE START OF THE
BEGINNING YOU HAVE THE SAME
CAST THE CHARACTERS THE DEEP
STATE CALL ME STRUCK PAGE.
MCCABE ALL THESE OTHERS THEY
START WITH SAVING HILLARY
CLINTON FROM A CLEAR VIOLATION
OF THE ESPIONAGE I ESPIONAGE
ACT YOU CITE THE LAW I HAVEN'T
BURNED INTO MY BRAIN EIGHTEEN
USC SEVEN NINETY THREE THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ME AND YOU
IS YOU CAN GIVE ME THE
SUBSECTIONS AND BITE IN DETAIL.
AND THEN IT WAS THE SUBPOENAED
EMAILS DELETED BLEACH BUT
HAMMERS DEVICES THE WHOLE ALL
OF IT COMBINED. AND THEN IT WAS
RUSSIA RUSSIA RUSSIA. THEY WERE
WARNED BEFORE THE FIRST FINDS
APPLICATION THAT WILL GET THE
BULK OF INFORMATION IN THE
APPLICATION SAYS AT THE TOP OF
A FISA WARRANT VERIFIED RIGHT.
THE BULK OF INFORMATION WAS
HILLARY CLINTON'S IRONICALLY
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR. DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER MISINFORMATION
IT BECAME EVEN THE NEW YORK
TIMES CONCLUDED THAT. AND IT
WAS USED TO TAKE AWAY THE
RIGHTS OF LAW PER AND PAGE IS
CONSTANT RIGHTS AND CIVIL BUT
IT WAS DONE TO SPY ON DONALD
TRUMP THE CANDIDATE. TO SPY ON
DONALD TRUMP IN HIS TRANSITION
TEAM AND IN THE WORDS OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR- DEEP
INTO THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY. THEY
WERE WARNED BEFORE THE FIRST
WHY FISA WARRANT KATHLEEN
CATHOLIC AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT SAID DON'T TRUST
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IT'S
UNVERIFIED HILLARY PAID FOR IT
IT IS A POLITICAL AGENDA BRUCE
OR DID IT IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN THEY DID IT ANYWAY.
THEN IT GETS EVEN MORE
INSIDIOUS AND MORE EVIL BECAUSE
THIS FOR WARRANTS IN TOTAL
THREE RENEWAL APPLICATIONS
COLLEAGUES ON THE FIRST THREE-
ONE DAY SIGN ONE SALLY EIGHT
SIGN ONE CAPE SIGNED ONE CAPE
SIDE ROSENSTEIN ROD ROSENSTEIN
SIGNED THE LAST ONE. BASED IN
THE LAST INTERVIEW WE GAVE
BEFORE THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SAID OF KNOWING WHAT
I KNOW NOW I WOULD NOT HAVE
SIGNED IT. IT WAS FALSE
INFORMATION FROM THE BEGINNING
AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT THEY
DRAG THE COUNTRY THROUGH HEALTH.
THEY ABUSED THEIR POWER AND
THEY DID IT TO TAKE DOWN A
PRESIDENT THAT INSURANCE POLICY
FIRST THEY WANTED TO STOP HIM
FROM BECOMING PRESIDENT THAT'S
WHY THEY SAVE HILLARY. AND THEY
DIDN'T APPLY THE LAWS EQUALLY
IN THAT CASE EQUAL APPLICATION
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW
THAT WAS GONE CONSTITUTIONAL
ORDER WAS DISRUPTED AND NOW YOU
HAVE A FEW POWERFUL FIGURES
THAT THINK THEY KNOW BETTER
THEY BELIEVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. WHO SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ELECTED NOW HERE'S WHERE IT
EVEN GETS WORSE NOW WE KNOW
WITH THE REVELATIONS RECENTLY
AND THAT'S LINDSEY GRAHAM'S
COMMITTEE PETER STRUCK SAID. WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY RUSSIA
COLLUSION. BUT THEY KEPT THE
GONE ANYWHERE THIS WAS EARLY IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN RIGHT THEY
SIGNED TWO MORE WARRANTS
THEREAFTER. RIGHT APPOINTED AS
SPECIAL COUNSEL APPOINTED A
SPECIAL COUNSEL. THAT NONE OF
THIS WHO KNEW WHAT WHERE WHEN
AND THEN IT GETS EVEN WORSE.
BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE WERE PUT
UNDER OATH THIS WAS THE
INFORMATION THAT CORRUPT.
COMPROMISED CONGENITAL LIAR OUT
OF SHIFT IRONICALLY THE ONLY
GUY ON TAPE. TRYING TO COLLUDE
WITH SOMEBODY THINKS IS A
RUSSIAN IT TURNS OUT TO BE
OSTER. HE SAYS. SO YOU HAVE
COMPROMISING MATERIALS ON
DONALD TRUMP- THEY GET A
COMPROMISE IN MIGHT BE A DEAL
THAT AND I LOVE THEM WHAT'S THE
NATURE OF THE COMPROMISE- DEAD
DEAD PIXIES NAKED TOP AND THEN
MAKE IT TO. HAS VLADIMIR'S SEEN
THEM ABOUT OF COURSE NOT A
MISSY- SO- NICK A PICK IT UP.
COMPROMISING MATERIAL. FUNNY
BUT NOT FUNNY. HILLARY'S PAID
FOR THE RUSSIAN DIRTY DOSSIER
HILLARY DID DECLARE DONALD
TRUMP THAT YOU HAVE STRUCK AND
EVERYBODY ON THE SEVENTH FLOOR
OF THE FBI BUT DOJ RIGHT MOST
POWERFUL PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
TAKE WHAT THEY KNEW TO BE TRUE
AND THEY DON'T GO BACK WHICH IS
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO BY LAW YOU
POINTED THAT OUT TO ME FIRST.
AND UPDATE THE APPLICATION. ALL
THEN DEPART RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
SO MANY EXAMPLES WHERE THEY GOT
TO THE SUB SOURCE THAT THEY
INTERVIEWED IN JANUARY JANUARY
TWENTY FIRST. OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO THREE SEPARATE
DAYS OF INTERVIEWS THE SUB
SOURCE SAID THIS WAS BARTOK
LITERALLY SAID PARK TALK YOU
WERE THE FIRST TO SAY AFTER
READING AND I READ AFTER YOU.
THAT WHEN YOU READ THE DOSSIER
IT'S LIKE RIDICULOUSLY FUNNY
RIGHT IN A SICK WAY BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T BELIEVE ANY OF IT. L.
THEN WE FIND OUT THEY DIDN'T
THINK THEY HAD IMPROVED THEY
THEY HAD NO INFORMATION ALSO
CONFIRM TO THIS VERY IMPORTANT
JANUARY FIFTH OVAL OFFICE
MEETING. BIDEN IS THERE. HE'S
THE ONE THAT MENTIONS THE LOGAN
ACT IN THAT MEETING AS- AS WE
NOW KNOW FROM PETER'S TRUCKS
PERSONAL NOTES- OBAMA IS THEY
ARE SAYING GET OUR PEOPLE ON
THIS AND MAYBE YOU SHOULDN'T
TELL THE INCOMING
ADMINISTRATION THINGS ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY- WHAT SUSAN
RICE WAS THERE WELL THAT WAS
JANUARY FIFTH FIFTEEN DAYS
LATER NOW WE KNOW WHY SHE WENT
BACK IN MEMORIALIZE HE SAID DO
EVERYTHING BY THE BOOK. BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THEY DID SHE KNEW I
DIDN'T DO EVERYTHING RIGHT. SEE
YA AND SALLY YATES ADMITS SHE
WAS SHOCKED THAT BARACK OBAMA.
KNEW EVERYTHING ABOUT GENERAL
FLYNN AND THE CALL WITH THE HIS
SOON. TO BE RUSSIAN COUNTERPART
KINSLEY ACT. AT THE IRONY TO
WHEN YOU GO THEN TO THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WHEN WE
FINALLY GOT THOSE TRANSCRIPTS.
ALL OF THESE OFFICIALS SAID
THAT THEY HAD. ALSO DID THE
SAME THING WITH THEIR SOON TO
BE COUNTERPARTS FROM THE GOING
INTO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
BUT THEY ALSO THE OTHER SAME
THING AND THAT IS THAT THEY HAD
NO EVIDENCE OF ANY COLLUSION.
BUT THEY DID IT A- BUT- WHEN WE
WHEN THIS FINALLY A IT'S GOING
TO BE VERY FASCINATING TO SEE.
WHAT DORM AND BAR ULTIMATELY DO
HERE. I BELIEVE THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING AND
INCONTROVERTIBLE. THAT THIS WAS
THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER. I
BELIEVE THE PEOPLE LIED MY
SOURCES ARE NOW TELLING ME THAT
THERE ARE. LOWER RANKING
OFFICIALS. YES SOME THAT WE'VE
NEVER EVEN HEARD OF. THAT ARE
TELLING THE TRUTH AND HAVE
EVIDENCE TO. BACK IT UP IT WAS
SPYING ON ON ANOTHER SIDE OF
THIS AND THAT WAS ACROSS THE
POND IF YOU WILL WHAT I ALWAYS
SAY GEE I WONDER WHAT THE
PEOPLE IN GREAT BRITAIN WERE
DOING ALL THE PEOPLE IN. ITALY
WERE DOING OR SOME OF OUR
COUNTERPARTS IN IN AUSTRALIA
BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE AN
INTELLIGENCE SIDE OF ALL OF
THIS. AND WE NOW KNOW SPLIT
WITH THE THAT WE KNOW THAT
THEIR ALLIES IN THE MALL REPORT
ABOUT JOSEPH THIS FOOD FOR
EXAMPLE. USE WESTERN
INTELLIGENCE WE WERE
OUTSOURCING SOME OF THE SPINE
ON AROUND SAYING GO TO OUR TO
CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN LAW THAT'S
RIGHT. ON YOU ONE WHAT WOULD
HAPPENED. IF THE FBI. HAD
ACTUALLY BEEN HONEST THAT WE
HAVE NO EVIDENCE. THAT IT'S ALL
AN INVENTED WHY. I WANT TO TURN
TO WHEN HE CAN I JUST SAY WHAT
I THINK THEY'LL- LISA PAGE SET
AND RIGHT NEXT. NO THAT IT WAS
THAT'S NO THEY THERE. AND LISA
PAGE SAID THIS IS PRETTY MUCH
THE SAME ONLY TALKING TO THEM.
THEIR OWN LITTLE MINIATURE AT
NOW WE KNOW THERE WERE TELLING
OTHERS RIGHT AT PAGE- ONE
TWENTY FOUR. HOW DOES THE FBI
GET AWAY WITH TURNING ITS
POWERFUL TOOLS ON THE MAN THE
UNITED STATES CITIZEN THREE
ELECTED AS PRESIDENT. HOW DID
WE END UP WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL WHO COMPLETELY IGNORES
FBI ABUSE AND INSTEAD SPENDS
TWO YEARS. TERRORIZING THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE THE ANSWER IS
THIS ONE SO. MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS. OKAY OR YOU THAT THIS ONE
WILL ACTUALLY BE HELD ACCOUNT
CRIMINAL. WELL LET ME BELIEVE
BACKTRACK IF I SAY THE TITLED
WHAT THE BOOK IS LIVE FREE OR
AMERICAN ICE. IF WE DON'T GET
IT RIGHT IT IS NOT A PRICE TO
PAY. JUSTICE IS THAT IN AMERICA.
THIS IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC I START OUT THE BOOK
YOU KNOW OR PUBLIC IF YOU CAN
KEEP IT RIGHT IN FRANKLIN AND
FRANKLIN. AND IF YOU DON'T THAT
CONSTITUTION YOU'RE THE LAWYER
HERE YOU'RE MORE VERSED IN THIS
THAN I AM. AND WHAT I DID THAT
IS THE FOUNDATION OF OUR ENTIRE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THE RULE OF
LAW. THE PRINCIPLE OF EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW AND EQUAL
APPLICATION UNDER OUR LAWS THEN
NO LONGER EXIST I WOULD READY
ARGUE. THAT IS MISSING. BECAUSE
THE TREATMENT OF PAPADOPOULOS
WITHHOLDING EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION IN HIS CASE OR FOR
A PROCESS CRIME OF LYING TO
CONGRESS AND ROGER STONE'S CASE
WHERE TWENTY NINE GUYS AND
TACTICAL GEAR FROGMAN PREDAWN
RAID GUNS DRAWN- AND CNN
CAMERAS TO OFF OKAY THAT'S AN
ABUSE OF POWER SAME OF PAUL
MANAFORT PAUL MANAFORT'S CASE
WAS DEAD GONNA BURIED POLITICAL
DESCRIBES HOW IT WAS A DNC
OPERATIVE THAT GOT THAT ADDED
OUT OF MOTHBALLS BECAUSE THEY
WANTED HER TRUMP. THEN YOU ADD
TO THAT. ALL OF THE GENERAL
FLOW I MADE THE WE TREATED
THIRTY YEAR WAR HERO BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T THINK HE WAS LYING
BUT THEY SAID THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO GO AFTER HIS SON WAS
IN BUSINESS WITH THEM. UNLESS
HE SIGNED THAT PAPER. HE WAS
BEING A GOOD FATHER HE SIGNED
THE PAPER TO SAVE HIS SON YES.
THAT'S WHAT HE DID AND THEY
MADE HIM DO IT. AND HE STILL
CAN'T YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
FOREVER FOR HIM TO GET THE
JUSTICE IN HIS CASE. SO THE
ANSWER IS. FORGET IT LOOK I'M
GONNA BE VERY BLUNT HERE.
REPUBLICS FAILED. HIS AMERICA
CAN FAIL AMERICA K. WE KNOW IT
CAN COLLAPSE THE BIGGEST PART
THAT I'M TRYING TO THE POINT
I'M TRYING TO MAKE AS I GO
THROUGH WHAT HAS MADE AMERICA I
BELIEVE THE GREATEST COUNTRY
GOD HAS GIVEN MAN THE ANSWER
SIMPLY IS FREEDOM HELLO.
CAPITALISM AGAINST SOCIALISM
NOW I HAVE THE MOST RADICAL
GROUP OF EXTREME SOCIALIST THAT
ARE THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE
OFFERING THIS RADICAL AGENDA
GIVE THE HISTORY THE RISE
RADICALS I GAVE THE TWENTY
TWENTY UTOPIAN VISION WE TALKED
AT LENGTH ABOUT THE GREEN NEW
DEAL I TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT
BOLSHEVIK BERNIE'S ECONOMIC
POLICIES I'VE TALKED AT LENGTH
ABOUT BETO BOZOS ASSAULT ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT THAT SCHUMER
PELO SEE BIDEN A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF FAILURE. GREG I
IF THEY'RE PUT IF WHAT THEY ARE
RUNNING ON IS EVER IMPLEMENTED
BYE BYE AMERICAN PIE. IT'S OVER.
AMERICA WE WHAT WILL BE. CHANGE
FOR EVER. IT WILL BE
IRREPARABLE DAMAGE WILL BE DONE
IF THOSE POLICIES THAT THEY'RE
STATING PUBLICLY ARE
IMPLEMENTED HOW SERIOUS SEMI
SERIOUS AS A HEART ATTACK SYRIA
IS THAT YOU KNOW THIS ALL GOES
AWAY I'LL TELL YOU WHAT ELSE IS
GOING TO HAPPEN. BECAUSE I AND
I KEEP GOING BACK TO THE CITY'S
YOU KNOW BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
EXPERIMENT RIGHT OKAY YOU GOT
THIS FORM OF SOCIALISM AND HIGH
TAXATION AND ENDLESS
BUREAUCRACY- THAT EXIST IN
STATES LIKE NEW YORK. IS STATES
LIKE ILLINOIS CITIES LIKE NEW
YORK CITY BALTIMORE CHICAGO
STATES LIKE OF CALIFORNIA-
OREGON- THE WASHINGTON STATE
SEATTLE AND PORTLAND THE CITY'S
YOU KNOW ANECDOTALLY WHY IS IT.
THE BIGGEST MASS EXISTS IN THE
COUNTRY IS THAT OUT OF THOSE
BLUE STATES RUN LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES. WELL
REASONS OBVIOUS PEOPLE RUNNING
AWAY FROM BURDENSOME
BUREAUCRACY HIGH TAXES AND LESS
REGULATION. BROKEN PROMISES
WASTE ABOUT FRAUD AND ABUSE.
AND HERE'S THE THING HOW WAS IT
HOW OF. THAT YOU WANT TO MOVE
OUT OF. SO FRANCISCO LA GO TO
TEXAS. YOU HOLKAR WITH GONNA.
GOVERNOR HUG WAS THE FIRST
POINT THIS TO ME. ABOUT FIVE
BUCKS TO THAT TWENTY FIVE BUCKS
TO GO FROM CAL TO DRAG YOUR
CRAP YOU'RE STUCK ARE WHAT I. A
MOVE OR THE LIKE TO HAVE BEEN A
BY LAW. I WAS A RADIO TRACK
FROM YEARS. AND IT IT BUT IF
YOU TAKE THAT'S U. HAUL BACK.
YOU'LL PAY TO FIVE ON. FOUR
HUNDRED AND YOU COULD PROBABLY
THE- LOWER RATES MANALAH I
COULD YOU HOW FACE. IS A LEAVE
TO TRY BACK BECAUSE WHAT THE
GOING TO MADE. AT THE DISEASE.
RISK OF THE PANDEMIC. IN NEW
YORK NEW JERSEY CONNECTICUT
PENNSYLVANIA MICHIGAN.
CALIFORNIA DID A LITTLE BETTER
I CREDIT GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
FOR THAT HE WOULD DID PRETTY
WELL THERE- AND THEN THE
LAWLESSNESS AND THE ANARCHIST
TAKEN OVER. THERE ADD TO THAT
THE LACK OF SAFETY SECURITY
BLACK EDUCATION SOCIALISM
GOVERNMENT RUN SCHOOLS.
GOVERNMENT CAN'T PROTECT ITS
CITIZENS. AND I'M JUST TELLING
YOU THIS IS A MICROCOSM THIS IS
A PREVIEW OF COMING ATTRACTIONS
TO THE UNITED STATES. I SOUND
WILL DIRE AND MAYBE NOT AS
OPTIMISTIC. AS MAYBE SOME
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE. WELL I'M NOT
OPTIMISED AT THIS A DOCTOR. I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE MEDIA
BECAUSE YOU DO A GREAT LANCS
MOB THE MEDIA MOB DESCRIBED IN
THE LIBERAL MAINSTREAM MEDIA
YOU ARGUE THEY ARE SO OBSESSED
WITH THEIR PATHOLOGICAL HATRED
FOR TRUMP THEY'VE DROPPED ALL
SEMBLANCE OF OBJECTIVITY THEY
SPREAD LIES DISTORTION AND
PROPAGANDA HOW DESTRUCTIVE HAS
THE MEDIA MOB DAN HAVE THEY
SQUANDERED ALL TRUST I CAN'T
EVEN GIVE ENOUGH ADJECTIVES. TO
DESCRIBE THE WORST PART IS IT'S
99% OF THE MEDIA. YOU KNOW FAKE
NEWS CNN IS FAKE NEWS TO THE
PRESIDENT'S CREDIT HE IS
BRANDED THEM FOR WHO THEY ARE
WE'VE TALKED AS CONSERVATIVES
I'M THIRTY THREE YEARS IN RADIO
AND MY TWENTY FIFTH YEAR FOX
ISN'T EXACTLY MY FIRST RODEO
GREG. AND WE'VE ALWAYS TALKED
ABOUT MEDIA BIAS NOR ABOUT
MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER FOR ALL
THESE YEARS. IT'S NEVER BEEN
THIS BAD THE EXAMPLE I USE IS
IT'S EVERY SECOND EVERY MINUTE
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
EVERY MONTH. EVER SINCE THAT
MAN AND HIS WIFE CAME DOWN THAT
ESCALATOR IN TRUMP TOWER. THEY
BUT ON A MISSION TO DESTROY HIS
PRESIDENCY. WITH THE HELP OF
SOME VERY POWERFUL PEOPLE THE
DEEP STATE THAT THINK THEY'RE
SMARTER THAN WE SMELLIE WALMART
SHOPPER TRUMP VOTERS. ARE
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES AS
HILLARY CALLED US OR THAT CLING
TO OUR GOD BIBLES GUNS AND
RELIGION. OR AS BIDEN SAYS WE
GET A CHANCE TO REWRITE THE
ECONOMY AND TRANSFORM AMERICA.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN. WELL WE
KNOW WHO SURROUNDED HIMSELF
WITH. SO THE MOB THEY DON'T
TELL THE TRUTH THEY LIED ABOUT
RUSSIA THEY GOT IT WRONG THEY
LIED THEY HYPED IT WAS SMEAR
SLANDER LIBIS MERCHANTS
CHARACTER ASSASSINATION YOU
NAME IT THEY DID IT ALL WELL
AND YOU WERE DEMONIZED FOR
TAKING A VERY STRONG POSITION
THAT WAIT A MINUTE WHERE'S THE
EVIDENCE. THIS IS A HOAX YOU
GOT IT RIGHT BECAUSE NEWLY
DISCOVERED DOCUMENTS CERTAINLY
PRODUCE YOU AND THE MEDIA GOT
IT WRONG HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU
FEEL. YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE A BIG VICTORY LAP
BUT- IN AISLE NUMBER ONE WE
DON'T HAVE TIME THIS TOO MUCH
OF THE TO MANY OTHER THINGS TO
DO. WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE IF
THEY WOULD ADMIT THAT THEY'VE
BEEN WRONG WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE
IF THEY WOULD RETRACT AND
APOLOGIZE AND CORRECT. YOU KNOW
I MAKE MISTAKES AND WHEN I DO
IT GONE AFTER SORRY I MESSED UP
NO THEY'RE HAPPY WITH THEIR
PULITZER PRIZE WELL YEAH THEY
GET PULLED SURPRISES FOR FALSE
THAT FOOTBALL STORIES RIGHT.
THE WHAT IT WAS SCARY AT PART
OF IT THOUGH TO BE. AS I
MENTION YOU IN ARANTES. K. MORE
MANY OF US GREG NOW TWENTY. IN
CONGRESS ALL IN TO GET TO THE
TRUE. FIFTEEN MORE TWELVE. TEN
FIFTEEN. OKAY WE WENT UP
AGAINST THE ENTIRE MEDIA
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX WE TOLD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE TRUTH YOU
KNOW AND HOPEFULLY JUSTICE IS
ON THE OTHER END OF IT I'LL
TELL YOU AS SOMEBODY THAT YOU
KNOW HIS MOM AS I TOLD YOU
EARLIER WAS A PRISON GUARD DAD.
YOU KNOW FAMILY COURT PROBATION
I TO FAMILY MEMBERS THAT GOT TO
BE FBI SPECIAL AGENTS THEY WERE
DEDI IN MY FAMILY THEY WERE THE
HIGHEST OF THE HIGH THAT WAS
THE ULTIMATE SO MANY RELATIVES
DISTANT COUSINS AT CENTRE ALL
BECAME COPS. HE'S HONORABLE
PEOPLE AND I HAVE TO NOW GO
TAKE ON THE F. B. I. I DID TOO
I GO DID WENT AGAINST THE VERY
FIBER OF MY BEING BUT WE WERE
RIGHT AND THEY DID ABUSE THEIR
POWER AND THEY DID A NORMA'S
DAMAGE TO NOT JUST PRESIDENT
TRUMP BUT THE PRESIDENCY ITSELF
THE INSTITUTION AND DIRECTOR
RAY NEEDS TO GET ITS ACT
TOGETHER AND FIX THE PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE
WORLD. GET OUT OF THE WAY I
KNOW WE USED IDEA WITH CHRIS
REVERBERATE THE HIGHLIGHT IT
WON'T HAPPEN I WANT TO COACH
YOU ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP NO
PRESIDENT IN THE MODERN ERA HAS
HAD TO TAKE SUCH UNPRECEDENTED
SUSTAINED ATTACKS BY BOTH
LIBERAL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
AND THE MEDIA MOB IN AN ATTEMPT.
TO DESTROY HIM. M. DOWN. YOU
THAT IN THE END. OF THAT POWER
FORCE MAKES. IN THE ELECTION
CAME CLOSE THEM. EVER SHE- I
MEAN IMAGINE HOW THE BREAST HIM.
YOU ONE TAKE UP. UNDERSTAND THE
LIBERALS CARE ABOUT UPS OF
JUSTICE RIGHT AFTER THE MALL
REPORT CAME OUT. THEY DIDN'T
CARE AT ALL ABOUT THE BROKEN
THE BLEACH BIT SUBPOENAED
EMAILS DELETED THE DEVICE
BUSTED THE SIM CARDS REMOTE
HILLARY CLINTON HILLARY CLINTON
JUST CORRECT. THEY DIDN'T CARE
THEY CARE ABOUT- RUSSIA RUSSIA
THEY DIDN'T CARE ABOUT HER
RUSSIAN DIRTY DOSSIER. THEY
CARE ABOUT QUID PRO QUOS HE GOT
JOE ON TAPE BRAGGING YOU'RE NOT
GETTING THE BILLION DOLLARS AND
LAST YOU FIRED THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO
EXPERIENCE ON WHO'S BEING PAID
MILLIONS AND THAT'S ONLY THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG I CALLED THE
BIDEN CRIME FAMILY AT THIS
POINT. A SO IT'S NOT TRUE THAT
THEY'RE SEEKING. THEY HAVE THE
BIGGEST INTO TWO TO ANY
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN IS THE MOB
IN THE MEDIA. ONE OF THE
REASONS YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN THE
HIGHEST RATED SHOW IN CABLE FOR
SO LONG. IS THAT WE DO TELL A
STORY AND GIVE NEWS AND
INFORMATION YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO GET ANYWHERE ELSE AND WE
ACTUALLY DIG FOR THE TRUTH. AND
WE DON'T RUSH TO JUDGMENT AND
WE BELIEVE IN THE CONSTITUTION
AND JUSTICE THESE THINGS
PRINCIPLES LIKE THIS MATTER
NOW. SUCCESS YOU KNOW HOW DO
YOU DEFINE SUCCESS EVEN IN THE
BACK OF MY BRAIN ASSUMING THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO CHOKE
ON THE WORDS WE COULD NOW
PROJECTED DONALD J. TRUMP AT
BEEN REELECTED THE FORTY FIFTH
PRESIDENT THE UNITED STATES BY
THE WAY. THAT WILL BE WORTH THE
PRICE OF ADMISSION ON STEROIDS
AND HUMAN GROWTH HORMONE.
BECAUSE THEY THINK THEY GOT
THIS LOCKED UP BUT- IF THEY
HAVE TO IF TO ME I WORRY. IF
THIS IS NOW THAT WE'RE
INDOCTRINATION IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM HAS GOTTEN US THAT THEY
NO LONGER HIDE THEIR
RADICALISM. AND THEY'VE
CONVINCED YOUNGER GENERATION
CENTER LEFT IS WHERE AMERICA
GOES BUT IT'S REALLY HARD LEFT.
COULD YOU DONALD TRUMP WILL BE.
AT BEST BUYING AMERICA TIME NOW
HOW DO YOU FIX THAT IS IT IS
GONNA BE A PROCESS OF
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS OF
UNDERSTANDING FREEDOM WHAT DOES
FREEDOM MEAN FREEDOM MEANS THAT
NOT EVERYTHING IS SECURED YOU
HAVE THE GOD GIVEN TALENTS AND
ABILITIES THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS NOT THE GUARANTEE
YOU'RE GOING TO GET. BUT DO YOU
HAVE THE CHANCE LISTEN I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT. AMERICANS
CAN'T FAIL LET'S PUT LET'S
CREATE IMAGINE IN NEW YORK CITY
CHICAGO SEATTLE LA SAN
FRANCISCO. WHERE THERE IS
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF PORTLAND.
AND LET'S IMAGINE THAT THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM IS RIGOROUS
EDUCATION. LET'S IMAGINE THAT
THE RUNGS OF THE LADDER THAT I
ARGUE ARE MISSING FROM THESE
STATES OF SOCIALISM
EXPERIMENTAL STAGE OF SOCIALISM
ARE PUT BACK IN PLACE I
ACTUALLY THEY HAVE AN IDEA I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE K. THROUGH
TWELVE CURRICULUM. ONLINE
AVAILABLE FOR FREE FOR EVERY
PARENT GRANDPARENT LOVING
NEIGHBOR. THAT IF THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM IS FAILING THEN THEY CAN
GO FOLLOW THE CURRICULUM ONLINE
TO GUARANTEE THE EDUCATION THAT
THESE LIBERAL STATES HAVE
FAILED TO DELIVER ON. DICK I
CAN'T HELP WITH SAFETY AND
SECURITY LESS OF COURSE THE
INSURRECTION ACT IS PUT IN
PLACE THEY DON'T WANT ANY HELP.
IF YOU DO THAT WE CAN SAVE
AMERICA. AND BIDEN SAVING
AMERICA. YOU KNOW WHAT IS IT
BEING LOWER TAXES LIMITED
GOVERNMENT GREATER FREEDOM. WE
HAVE GOT TO ACCEPT THAT. ENERGY
IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD'S
ECONOMY WE GOT A PRODUCE IF WE
GOT TO SECURE OUR BORDERS PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH NOT
APPEASEMENT YOU DON'T DOUBLE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION IN
CASH AND OTHER CURRENCY ON THE
TARMAC OF MODELS THE CHANT
DEATH TO AMERICA. IF WE PUT
PEOPLE THAT RESPECT OUR
CONSTITUTION OUR FOUNDATION FOR
THE RULE OF LAW IN THE COURTS-
SECURE OUR BORDERS. IF WE GIVE.
YOU KNOW. HEALTH SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS. HEALTHCARE
COOPERATIVES THAT I CAN PROVE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN ARE WORKING
AND SAVING PEOPLE MONEY AND IT
WOULD GIVE EVERY AMERICAN EVEN
CONCIERGE HEALTH CARE WITH
ACCESS TO A DOCTOR TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. USING NEW TECHNOLOGY
LIKE TELEMEDICINE JUST LIKE
TELL EDUCATION WHICH COULD SAVE
A FORTUNE. YOU KNOW THERE'S
NOTHING AMERICA CAN'T DO WE
HAVE BEEN A LOT THE SHINING
CITY ON A HILL SOME PEOPLE WILL
ARGUE IN THIS DAY AND AGE WELL
WE AFTER WE'RE ALWAYS BEEN
EVIL. WE'RE NOT A PERFECT
COUNTRY BUT THIS MAN THOMAS
PAINE ONE SAID. WHEN UPROAR THE
PEOPLE ARE PERFECT WITH THE
GUIDES AND DICTATES OF ONE'S
CONSCIENCE IRRESISTIBLY BEATTY
WROTE IN COMMON SENSE THERE BE
NO NEED FOR ANY LAW GIVER. THAT
NOT BEING THE CASE BECAUSE
HUMAN BEINGS ARE FLAWED. AND
SEN AND WE HAVE A PROPENSITY
FOR GOOD OR EVIL. I BELIEVE
WE'RE ALL CREATED BY GOD BUT
THAT PROPENSITY WHICH CHIP
WHICH PATH YOU CHOOSE OR MAYBE
CHOSEN. FOR YOU BECAUSE OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. YOU KNOW HE SAYS
IN THE BEST CASE. IS A NEST
EVIL. ITS WORST CASE IN THE
TOLERABLE. THE IN POWER ONE IS
ON THE BALLOT THIS YEAR. THE
WRECKAGE THE CARNAGE TO THE
ECONOMY INCALCULABLE
IRREPARABLE HARM TO OUR
FREEDOMS INCALCULABLE. YOU KNOW
THIS IS A THIS IS A WARNING CRY
TO EVERY AMERICAN I DON'T WANT
TO WRITE THIS BOOK YOU WRITE
GREAT BOOKS IT'S TOO HARD I'LL
BE VERY HONEST IT IS HARD WORK
I DID IT BECAUSE THIS IS THE
MOMENT. OF A LIFETIME. LIVE
FREE OR THIS GREAT COUNTRY. AS
WE KNOW IT IF THE POLICIES OF
BIDEN BOLSHEVIK BERNIE AOC
SCHUMER PELOSI AND BETO BOZO.
ARE IN FACT I ARGUE WILL NEVER
RECOVER. EVER OUR FUTURE CAN BE
EITHER BRIGHT OR GLOOMY. PRETTY
MUCH END NOVEMBER MAY DECIDE
THAT IF I SAY IN THE BOOK.
GOING BACK TO THE VERY
BEGINNING IS IT IS IT A
MONARCHY OR IS IT A REPUBLIC.
REPUBLICANS AT STAKE HERE.
CAPITALISM SOCIALISM ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE OR DEPENDENCE.
OPEN BORDERS CLOSED BORDERS
LAWLESSNESS OR LONG LISTLESS
ANARCHY OR LAW AND ORDER AND
SAFETY AND SECURITY FIXING
AMERICA'S BROKEN EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM TO HIGHER TAXES LOWER
TAXES PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
APPEASEMENT TOP TRADE DEALS
WITH PARTNERS. MANUFACTURING
GOODS AT HOME SAVING OUR
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY. SO DID
OLUM MAYBE I ADD A SENSE THIS
IS A HEAVY INTERVIEW WITH BUT-
I FEEL IN ALL. WITH ALL THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT I'VE ACCUMULATED
THREE YEARS OF RADIO NOW MY
TWENTY FIFTH YEAR FOX I COULD
TELL YOU RIGHT NOW. IF PEOPLE
ARE FOOLISH ENOUGH TO THINK
THAT THE AMERICA'S FREEDOMS ARE
ALWAYS GUARANTEED READ THE
WORDS OF RONALD REAGAN THAT I
PUT IN THE BOOK RIGHT. THAT
FREEDOM IS ALWAYS BUT ONE
GENERATION AWAY FROM EXTINCTION.
AND IT'S NOW OUR
RESPONSIBILITY. TO PRESERVE
PROTECT DEFEND. FREEDOM AND
LIBERTY FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS. THAT'S HOW SERIOUS
I SEE IT AS A RATHER JOKE
AROUND AND TALK ABOUT BASEBALL.
WELL TALK ABOUT FOOTBALL I READ
TALK ABOUT OTHER THINGS WE
COULD TALK ABOUT A MONTH OVER
BEFORE. LET'S HOPE THE MEDIA
CHOKES ON THOSE WORDS TO CHOKE
ON. THE WAY THE PRICE OF
ADMISSION LET'S SEE THAT. WE
COULD HELP. PROJECT DONALD J.
TRUMP BEEN REELECTED YOU MAY.
THEM HAVING TO SAY THAT. I LIVE
THROUGH EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA.
ONLY WE CAN LIVE THROUGH A
YEARS OF BOLSHEVIK BURR A-
JUDGE BLOW C. XU OBEYED.
SHANAHAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE NAME OF YOUR NEW BOOK
COMING OUT IS LIVE FREE OR DIE
I READ IT COVER TO COVER EACH
AND EVERY DAY I SAW YOU MARKUP.
IT'S BEAUTIFULLY WRITTEN THE
ARGUMENTS ARE COMPELLING WEALTH
RESEARCH THANK YOU THOROUGHLY
SOURCED AND YOU TOLD ME YOU
WERE NEVER GOING TO WRITE
ANOTHER BOOK AGAIN ONE YEAR AGO
AND HERE IT IS YOU DID IT AND-
YOU KNOW I THINK- THE READERS
IN AMERICA- WELL YOU DEMOCRATIC
TO. OUR ALL I WANT IS IF
ANYBODY IF YOU SAY TO YOURSELF
WELL WHAT CAN I DO. IF ALL YOU
CAN DO IS VOTE. THANK YOU. IF
YOU CAN ADD PEOPLE THAT'S THIS
BOOK IS ABOUT DON'T BUY TO
SHARE PASS AROUND. MY LAST BOOK
I GAVE EVERY PENNY WAY CHARITY
IT'S NOT ABOUT IT FOR ME IS
ABOUT THE- THIS IS OUR THIS IS
A MATTER. ON THE VERGE. TIPPING
POINT. IT'S ON THE LINE. TO WIN
A LOT FOR. NOT EASY. YOU GOTTA
TAKE YOU GOTTA ONE FLOOR.
GEORGIA NORTH CAROLINA YOU
GOTTA TAKE I WHAT YOU GOT TO
GET OHIO. YOU GOTTA PICK OFF
PENNSYLVANIA WISCONSIN
HOPEFULLY MICHIGAN MAYBE
MINNESOTA WILL BE IMPLY. YOU
GOT HOLD ARIZONA FIGHT FOR
NEVADA. FIGHT FOR NEW MEXICO.
FIVE FOR NEW HAMPSHIRE. FIGHT
FOR THE SECOND CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IN MAINE. THEY ALL
MATTER. EVERY VOTE MATTERS
YOU'VE BEEN A GOOD SPORT- DUE
TO COVID IN SOCIAL STATUS AND
WE CHOSE ALL. DEGREE AND I JUST
ONE DAY IN AND OUT OF YOUR- AND
HERE'S WHAT HE LIKE A- YOUR
GRADES. ABOUT THANK YOU FOR
COMING AND I DON'T A RECALLING
A GOOD FRIEND SAME HERE. FOR
WITH US THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
IT AND THAT'S IT FOR THIS
SPECIAL EDITION. ON FOX NATION
I'M GREG JARRETT FOR BEING US.